a couple days ago the Supreme Court came
out with a decision essentially
rewriting employment law in the United
States the Democrats have been trying to
do this with the so called Equality Act
but had not gotten through Congress so
justice Gorsuch and a 6-3 majority of
the Supreme Court decided hey why not do
it ourselves and we will just rewrite
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 to pretend
that the Civil Rights Act of 1964
included sexual orientation and
transgenderism concepts in the case of
sexual orientation that clearly were not
included or in the case of gender
identity that nobody'd ever heard of
because it's crazy joining us to discuss
is Ryan Anderson he is the William Simon
research fellow at the Heritage
Foundation and founder and editor of
public discourse he's also the author of
when Harry became Sally responding to
the transgender moment Ryan thanks so
much for joining me show appreciate it
happy to be with you so what do you
think are the consequences of this
decision so you know it can put away we
can put aside the fact that I think it's
pretty obvious that there's a bad legal
decision that the Civil Rights Act did
not mean to encompass sexual orientation
people knew about gays and lesbians back
in 1964 and it certainly did not mean to
encompass men who believe they are women
because it seems that title 7 is now in
to wreak conflict with title Minds
haidle 9 protects biological women and
apparently title 7 now requires
biological men to be treated as
biological women if they so demand which
is which is bizarre
what are the actual ramifications of
this of this decision for employers in
the United States yeah I think you're
gonna see the collision you just
mentioned between title 7 and title 9 I
think that's gonna be answered by saying
that title 9 when it bans discrimination
the basis of sex that mean according to
Gore such a man who identifies as a
woman if you don't treat him as if he's
a woman you're discriminating against
him on the basis of his sex because
Gorsuch is logic here is that if two
people identify as women one of whom is
female and one of whom is male and if
you treat them differently you're
discriminating against them on the basis
of their sex so this will have impact
not just an employment law but I very
soon expect to see some lawyers on the
Left file a lawsuit to get this applied
to education law via title 9 and then
we'll see what it means for bathrooms
for locker rooms for sports teams
athletic competition it's going to have
a whole host of consequences in the
workplace pronoun you know about hostile
workplace doctrine so if you are an
employer and someone Rafi
to use the preferred pronouns that could
foster a hostile workplace and you as
the employer will not have a legal duty
to make that employee use the preferred
pronouns or to get rid of that employee
they're gonna be all sorts of litigation
that follows from this because as you
said the court just rewrote the law I
mean that that last point is is such a
telling one because the the entire logic
of the court is that transgenderism is
protected under sex discrimination
because you're discriminating against a
biological male because he's a
biological male if he says that he is
woman correct
so you're discriminating against him as
a man not as a woman you're
discriminating against him as a man but
if you say that he's a man you may be
discriminating law now that is exactly
right that that is the logic and there's
a simplistic logic to Gorsuch his
opinion where he says if the employee or
by extension the student would have been
treated different if the employer
student were a different sex that's an
instance of discrimination on the basis
of sex race would he's read into the law
as androgyny he's written to the law
that we can take no account of the
biological differences between men and
women boys or girls
otherwise we're discriminating on the
basis of their sex and that's not what
title seven or title nine required it it
said you can't have double standards it
didn't say you can't have any standards
at all so the real question for
religious institutions is obviously how
the Supreme Court draws the lines there
because when we're gonna see the most
conflict aside from the free speech
issues I mean first of all it seems to
me entirely bizarre that free speech
doctrine would allow laws that prevent
me from saying a biological fact like
that that's an incredible incredible
thing the idea that that free speech
doctrine would allow me to would force
me to be fired or create legal liability
on the basis that I have said something
that is a biological fact I mean that
how I guess that maybe the Supreme Court
upholds that idea that if I say that a
transgender male is in fact a woman that
I can now be fight that I should I must
be fired from my job or disciplined in
some way that that is now federal law
does not violate the First Amendment I
like how that is possible is beyond me
but you know there's room course
rewriting laws as they go I wonder how
close that comes to hate speech
legislation in effect
so I don't know how that would intersect
with hate speech but I think the way
that they're gonna do it with preferred
pronouns they would say you as a radio
so show hosts have a First Amendment
right to say that person X Y & Z is a
male or is a female but you have to use
the preferred pronouns because that's
not asserting anything that's just a way
of avoiding a hostile work environment
there's a case at the Sixth Circuit
right now involving a professor who
wasn't going to use preferred pronouns
got fired we're gonna see how the Sixth
Circuit handles that case and it might
get to the Supreme Court there are two
cases that we're waiting to hear answers
from the Supreme Court this term so you
live in the next two weeks we're going
to hear two ministerial exception cases
these are particularly Catholic school
teachers who've been dismissed from
their job and the court is going to tell
us how broad or how narrow who
constitutes a minister is and that's
going to determine the route of Liberty
part of this right how will we be able
to make employment decisions at
religious institutions but the question
you also raises you could be a religious
person working in a secular business
right hosting a secular radio show right
what are your freedom is going to be
what sort of liability are you gonna
have and I I don't see a clear answer to
that coming anytime soon the court when
it comes to the religious liberty
question and the the real question is as
you mentioned is the fact that if you
are a secular worker and a religious
institution so I went to Jewish day
school we had our Hebrew studies in the
morning and then we had our secular
subjects in the afternoon the secular ii
teachers were secular they were there
were science teachers but they're there
i'm sure we're behavioral requirements
that were placed upon them so that they
were not promulgating anti religious
messages in the classroom for example
you could see that completely overturn
you could see the catholic church forced
to employ transgender people or to pay
for transgender surgery in their
insurance coverage so we would reap
litigate presumably Little Sisters of
the Poor and and all this could get very
ugly very quickly
oh very much so because depending on how
they say who constitutes a minister for
the purpose of the ministerial exemption
it could be just teachers who teach
religion or it could be all teachers who
are meant to embody the true
of the religion right I mean there are
two ways in which you teach people about
religion one is I teaching them stuff at
the chalkboard the other is by living
your life in accordance with the sacred
dogmas the sacred teachings of your
religious community and we shouldn't
just think that ministering or teaching
only takes place with kind of their
verbal instruction I think we learn a
lot more by example right but the courts
going to answer that
you know either correctly or incorrectly
health care plans another big case last
week Trump's HHS finally three and a
half years later fixed a bad Obamacare
mandate that would have mandated
coverage of sex reassignment procedures
would have mandated hospitals and
doctors perform these procedures it's
unclear now what the law is going to be
on this in light of the title seven
ruling because if you apply the same
logic consistently it's going to suggest
a bad outcome here right the court isn't
always consistent right and so there's
been there's been some talk about the
possibility of a sort of fairness for
all Utah outcome David French has talked
about this a little bit we're talking
with professor Ryan Anderson of the
Heritage Foundation the idea that that
basically gorgeous Gorsuch has brought
into LGBTQIA employment rights but that
he is about to carve out all sorts of
significant religious exceptions to that
rule
yeah I hope that's the case but it also
does backfoot virtually all religious
people in the country by essentially
suggesting the only reason that you're
according court allowed to be a bigot is
because you're religious and this is a
case that you've seen from Cory Booker
and bethe O'Rourke which is that
religion is actually just cover for
bigotry you can't have any good faith
reason for example not to want your
third grade child taught by a man who
believes he's woman and the only reason
that you'd want to do that is because of
religious bigotry and the only way you
can get out of it is by invoking your
religious bigotry
it seems the Gorsuch made a decision
that is not just a decision about the
interpretation of law that is faulty but
a decision about human nature itself
that utterly denies the reality of sex
entirely
oh that's entirely correct I mean one is
that he shouldn't be legislating from
the bench his job is to adjudicate cases
he's a judge she's not a lawmaker and
everything you just described especially
the insights from David French but this
is a legislative
question right how do we balance a
coercive law like a shoji law with
permissive religious liberty
considerations but then the second point
is and why should this be limited to the
religious domain right why should it be
the general rule is you're a bigot but
you have a carve out for your bigotry in
your religious unclothed and then the
third point and what about all the
secular women right you don't need to be
religious to not want a boy in your
locker room to not have to lose a
championship track race to a boy who
identified as a girl right those aren't
religious liberty concerns those are
concerns about privacy enough safety
about basics fairness and equality and
sports and the question is why is the
court trying to make policy on these
questions right policymakers should make
policy and religious liberty isn't the
only concern here so even if David's
right that this is going to be some sort
of a grand compromise you talk
compromise given to us by you know 9
robe justices that still isn't a good
outcomes patient so for both procedural
and substantive reasons we should be you
know pretty upset about what course that
has done here professor Ryan Anderson of
the Heritage Foundation one of the
speculative ideas here was that perhaps
the reason that Roberts turned out in
the opinion so he could assign it to
Gorsuch as opposed to assigning it to
somebody like Ginsburg that he was going
to join the decision either way but he
wanted to be he knew Gort which way
course which was gonna vote but of
course it but if Roberts doesn't vote
for it then then Roberts doesn't get to
assign the opinion it just goes to
Ginsburg and instead you get a
full-scale anti-religious diatribe what
do you make of that particular argument
I mean there's some plausibility to that
we don't know obviously what the chief
thinks about this because he didn't
write under his own name it's
interesting that there weren't any
concurring opinions right didn't Berg
didn't write a concurring opinion going
kind of like whole-hog on this and maybe
that was the price of you know getting
the sixth vote so that course which gets
the pen and you know maybe that
minimizes damages if you look at what
Justice Ginsburg has said about sex
discrimination in the past she should
not have cited with courses in this case
in in the amicus brief that I filed on
this case I point out that Ginsburg said
sex discrimination requires double
standard
it's when you hold women to one standard
that you don't hold men to but this is
the same standard for all men and women
right no one can cross dress at work
whether you're male or female
men can't be wearing dresses women can't
be wearing coats and ties the the case
involved a funeral home director right
there was a dress code here so it wasn't
as if there was a standard that men were
exposed to but women weren't or women
were exposed to but men word was at
stake here was that there was a man who
wanted to present as a woman and so
that's not an instance of sex
discrimination but what we've seen here
is that this isn't actually about the
law
this is about a policy outcome and so
there were six justices who wanted a
certain policy outcome well all of this
is deeply disturbing stuff and I'm glad
that you're here to walk us through it
Ryan Anderson of the Heritage Foundation
check out his book when Harry became
Sally responding to the transgender
moment Ryan thanks much free time really
appreciate it
yep thank you
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
benton shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content